once Iran makes the decision to withdraw
from any kind of a deal everyone will
forget that the u.s. initiated the
collapse of the deal and global opinion
will be it's Iran's fault I have said
this to Iran on many occasions I don't
think they have any reason to withdraw
from the deal huge three days here in
Sochi very big talks high-profile talks
first we had the Chinese Foreign
Minister than the US Secretary of State
today the Austrian president got a lot
of topics almost every major crisis in
the world now was discussed here and of
course they talked about Iran Venezuela
Ukraine the wars in the Middle East
Syria Yemen they talked about financial
markets about oil about gas you know all
sorts of things but because front and
center was was around because it is
really getting into the dangerous phase
now the phase where everybody fears an
escalation and today Vladimir Putin was
asked about what Russia plans to do to
help resolve this crisis I see any
pressure may come on them when Russia is
not a fire brigade I cannot just go
around saving everything that is burning
around us we have played our part and we
are ready and willing to play this part
in future but it depends not just on us
but on our partners on the Europeans on
the US and on Iran itself the Europeans
the Russians in the Chinese have similar
views and the Iranian crisis they
believe it's gone too far and that the
best option for the world for all the
countries involved is to stick to the
Iranian nuclear deal of 2015 and even
the Europeans have called what the
United States is doing is dangerous and
provocative let's listen talk of the
impression I have is that any additional
pressure on Iran is only going to
undermine political relations even
further no matter how much we argue
about the probability of this happening
if the US continues putting pressure on
Iran at least to the risks of a crisis
as happened in Iraq several years ago
and in Europe no one wants that to
happen
unfortunately there's
easy solution to the Iranian crisis but
they at least talked about it and that
by the way was the takeaway yesterday
when might compel the US Secretary of
State visited and today Vladimir Putin
said that you know he now has a sense
that there's some willingness in in
Washington to repair restart relations
with with Russia they agreed yesterday
that you know they disagree on many
things they also agreed to start
repairing various communication channels
hotlines for example counterterrorism
intelligence financial political the
Vladimir Putin was also asked about the
potential meeting with Donald Trump and
he replied that at the g20 summit if the
Americans are willing if they want to
start the serious serious you know take
serious steps towards repairing
relations Russia is always willing
you